>> Tucker: ENJOY YOGA?
PLEASE STOP.
YOUR PROMOTING WHITE SUPREMACY.
A PROFESSOR OF RELIGIOUS STUDIES
AT MICHIGAN STATE ARGUED IN A
RECENT PIECE THAT YOGA SWAG IS
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF THE GLOBAL
SOUTH.
CATHY RUE IS THE PUBLISHER OF
CATALINA MAGAZINE AND MORE THAN
THAT OUR GUIDE TO THE CHANGING
LEFT AND WE'RE GLAD TO SEE YOU
AS ALWAYS, CATHY.
SO YOGA IS RACIST.
DO YOGA, FEW UNDERSTAND THE
CULTURE AND HISTORY OF THE
RELIGION BEHIND YOGA AND THEY'RE
SIMPLY ENJOYING IT FOR THE
PHYSICAL ASPECTS SO THEY'RE NOT
TRULY UNDERSTANDING YOGA AND
WHAT IT GOES BACK TO AND THEY
NEED TO IF THEY WANT TO
APPRECIATE IT AND IF NOT THEY'RE
SIMPLY GIVING INTO THIS VIEW
POINT OF WHITE SUPREMACY,
ACCORDING TO THIS PROFESSOR.
>> Tucker: SO IF YOGA RACIST IS
HOT YOGA MORE RACIST?
>> ALL WESTERN YOGA IS RACIST
ACCORDING TO THIS PROFESSOR.
SO YOGA PRACTICED HERE IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE OTHER WORLD.
WHITE WOMEN, UPPER CLASS, NOT
MINORITIES OR LATINOS OR
>> Tucker: THAT RIGHT THERE IS
SUSPECT.
CALL THE POLICE.
WHAT ABOUT TAI KWON DO.
THAT MAY BE BAN.
>> BY THIS AUTHOR'S STANDARDS
BUT HAS A PROBLEM WITH YOGA
INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX.
SO IF IT FALLS UNDER THAT --
>> Tucker: IF IT'S WRONG FOR
THE REST OF THE WORLD TO USE THE
INTERNET?
>> I THINK WE UNDERSTAND THE
CULTURE OF THE INTERNET AND
DOESN'T GO BACK TO THE
COLONIZATION OF INDIA AND WHAT
INDIANS HAS TO DO TO SHOW THEM
AND HOW IT CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES IN THE 19th AND 20th
CENTURY.
THE INTERNET WOULD NOT FALL
THAT WAS INVENTED BY THE GREEKS
IN THE WEST.
THE BASIS OF WESTERN
CIVILIZATION.
>> NO, YOGA WAS A WAY TO SHOW
COLONIZERS THEY WERE
INTELLIGENT --
>> Tucker: YOGA PREDATES IT BY
QUITE A BIT.
I'M INTERESTED, HOME PEOPLE INTO
YOGA IN THE UNITED STATES DO YOU
THINK VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP?
>> OH, WELL THE AUTHOR DIDN'T
TOUCH ABOUT THAT --
>> Tucker: BUT WHAT'S YOUR
NON-TRUMP VOTERS.
WOULD YOU SAY 1% OF PEOPLE WHO
PRACTICE YOGA VOTED TRUMP OR IS
THAT TOO HIGH.
>> MANY MIDDLE AND UPPER CLASS
WHITE WOMEN PRACTICE YOGA.
THOSE PEOPLE WHO FIT INTO THAT
CATEGORY AND ARE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS VOTE FORD TRUMP.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU STRUCK BY THE
FACT THAT THAT SERIES OF
DESCRIPTORS, UPPER MIDDLE CLASS,
WHITE, THAT'S KIND OF THE WHOLE
ARGUMENT ON THE LEFT NOW.
SO ANYTHING THAT HAS THOSE WORDS
ATTACHED IS BAD BECAUSE AND
ANYTHING THAT DOESN'T IS
SUPERIOR TO THAT.
>> YEAH, ACCORDING TO THE
UNDERSTAND IMMIGRANTS AND
MINORITIES AND PERHAPS HAVE MORE
PRIVILEGE AND ABLE TO EXPERIENCE
YOGA AND OTHER THINGS OTHER
GROUPS CANNOT EXPERIENCE.
>> Tucker: SO LAST QUESTION, IF
IN A MULTI-CULTURAL SOCIETY WE
LIVE IN -- AND I'M FOR THE BASIC
PRINCIPLE WHICH IS THERE'S COOL
THINGS FROM OTHER CULTURES AND
YOU SHOULD ENJOY THEM, WHEN DID
THE RULES CHANGE.
WE LIVE IN A MULTI-CULTURAL
SOCIETY BUT NOT ALLOWED TO ENJOY
COOL THINGS FROM OTHER CULTURES
AND IF YOU DO YOU SHOULD FEEL
GUILTY.
>> THE AUTHOR SAID BY NO MEANS
DON'T STOP DOING YOGA BUT
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE ONLY
UNDERSTANDING AN EIGHTH OF IT
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT PEOPLE WENT
THROUGH TO INTRODUCE THIS TO YOU
AND HAVE AN APPRECIATION, DON'T
WONDERFUL TRADITION BROUGHT TO
YOU FROM OTHER CULTURE.
>> Tucker: I SUSPECT DOWNWARD
DOG IS HARDER TO ENJOY IF YOU
HATE YOURSELF WHILE YOU DO IT,
WOULDN'T YOU THINK?
JUST KNOW MORE.
>> Tucker: MORE SELF-LOATHING.